[Música]
de 21 años y miembro de la guardia
nacional desde las fuerzas aéreas de
Estados Unidos Fue detenido acusado y
presentado audiencia por sustraer y
mantener documentos clasificados podría
pasar más de dos décadas en la cárcel de
tras convertirse en protagonista de las
últimas filtraciones de inteligencia
el jueves en su domicilio fue arrestado
por un equipo de agentes del FBI tras
descubrir que había robado y fotocopiado
estos documentos cada delito que se le
imputa puede acarrear hasta diez años de
cárcel vamos a hablar sobre este tema
con Francisco de girao quien es director
de defensa seguridad y aeroespacial de
la consultora atrevia Francisco gracias
a usted
Ojalá
mire desde los papeles del pentágono en
los años 70 que revelaron las mentiras
del gobierno respecto a la guerra de
Vietnam pasando por el watergate y luego
por Wikileaks porque se siguen
repitiendo las filtraciones Y es que
sorprende además que esta vez es un
joven de 21 años quien tuvo acceso a
información altamente clasificada
pues son las dos preguntas principales
la primera bueno ninguna tiene respuesta
fácil pero la primera Tenemos que tener
en cuenta que la comunidad de
inteligencia de Estados Unidos es la más
poblada del mundo
Cuanto más cuantas más personas tenemos
dedicadas
al ejercicio a la recolección y a la
producción de productos de inteligencia
aumentan las posibilidades lógicamente
de que que haya fugas como como ha sido
el caso la semana La semana pasada
Durante los últimos meses en caso
concreto de la información que tenía
Estados Unidos determinada información
que tenía Estados Unidos sobre la
situación de la guerra en Ucrania y las
posibilidades y las perspectivas de la
Guerra de Ucrania
El caso es así o sea es decir como
organización humana
no es perfecta y mucho menos
específicamente a la de Estados Unidos
que no solo tiene mucha población
una población
con números grandes dedicada como digo
al ejercicio de la profesión de
inteligencia sino además muchos
organismos O sea que intrínsecamente
acarrea unos problemas de
coordinación entre ellos que es verdad
que son más propios de la era pre 9/11
entonces de septiembre pero que también
están ahí por supuesto y lo de los 21
años sin duda claro es una respuesta
tiene también puede tener también su
explicación pero es verdad que es lo que
más llama la atención como un chaval
como un chico de 21 años puede tener
acceso a la información tan sensible de
alguna forma bueno acaba de ser
ascendido ya que se irá a soldado de
primera clase no tenía cualquier destino
estaba en una unidad de inteligencia de
la guardia nacional aérea a pesar de sus
cortos 21 años de edad y pero
evidentemente desde luego la base del
need to know dentro de la comunidad
inteligencia americana está muy
extendida es decir yo estoy seguro que
se consideraba que esa persona ese
profesional debía tener acceso a los
documentos que tuvo acceso lo que pasa
es que claro ha sorprendido a todo el
mundo que lo que hiciese es dedicarse a
filtrarlos en un chat dedicado a
videojuegos internet Bueno por un lado
está la preocupación de que se filtre
información clasificada para un gobierno
como el de Estados Unidos Pero por otro
lado están las preocupaciones que estas
filtraciones generan en torno al país y
a sus ocupaciones digamos de espionaje
en el pasado se supo que el gobierno por
ejemplo quería recopilar los datos
biométricos de los miembros de la ONU y
esta vez el escándalo divulga
información de espionaje que no
solamente va hacia Rusia que pues es su
enemigo declarado en este caso en el
conflicto con Ucrania sino también
espionaje sobre Ucrania que sería Pues
digamos su Aliado en este conflicto
el espionaje sobre amigos y enemigos
están viejo como el espionaje mismo es
decir lo que interesa es la recopilación
y la recolección de información Yo
entiendo que es preocupante y
escandaloso o no le parece a usted
yo creo que cuanta más información tenga
al margen por supuesto dentro de los
costes legales y demás cuanta más
información tengas mejores decisiones en
teoría vas a poder tomar No estoy
defendiendo ni muchísimo menos ningún
procedimiento que no sea legal y que no
esté arreglado pero creo que estoy
seguro que insisto Tener información y
recopilar información tanto de amigos
como de enemigos están viejo como el
mismo la misma profesión de la
inteligencia
mire la ley de espionaje que es una ley
federal está es muy antigua no fue
promulgada en el año 1917 y es la base
para condenas anteriores de personas que
compartieron información clasificada Qué
pasará ahora con ira Y pues si esto fue
Simplemente un acto imprudente y digamos
casi que de adolescente o algo que a
pesar de todo es considerado una falta
muy grave en el país
es que dice usted bien prácticamente
adolescentes que son 21 años se llama
muchísimo la atención Esto me acaba de
poder
consumir alcohol legalmente en Estados
Unidos hace cuatro días efectivamente
entonces
los tribunales lo dirán lo que está
claro es que ese tipo de filtraciones la
historia reciente nos dice que Estados
Unidos y el Gobierno Federal se lo toma
muy en serio Y aunque no deje de llamar
la atención esas imágenes que estamos
viendo de insisto un chico detenido por
el
hacer lo que presuntamente ha hecho
si se comprueba que ha cometido ese tipo
de
ilegalidades no sé si 20 años que es lo
máximo que le podría caer por esos dos
delitos de los que se le acusa pero
indemne parece no soy un experto en el
sistema legal americano intende parece
que es difícil que salga bueno mire
ahora el otro tema es las consecuencias
que esto pueda tener más allá de Este
joven o más allá digamos de de la imagen
de Estados Unidos se cree que esta
podría ser una de las brechas de
seguridad más grandes desde los casos de
Wikileaks en el 2010 cuando se compartió
recordemos más 700.000 archivos de
documentos y de cables diplomáticos en
ese momento la filtración comprometió a
Estados Unidos por su actuación en
Afganistán no por el bombardeo de
civiles qué repercusión puede tener
ahora esta filtración que tiene que ver
con el conflicto que está en los
titulares actualmente y es la Guerra de
Ucrania
fíjese filtración sobre la actuación de
Estados Unidos y también sobre el
espionaje aliados recuerdo que
probablemente fue uno de los ejes de
polémica mayores de Wikileaks
yo dudo sinceramente o sea es decir yo
no no creo que se pueda comparar la
filtración histórica de wikileak
simplemente por el volumen de documentos
con esto lo que pasa es que
evidentemente esto atañe a la Guerra de
Ucrania que es el asunto internacional
por excelencia en el que estamos todos
ocupados y preocupados pero no creo que
sea equiparable en ningún caso y creo
que de fondo Y de forma casi
intuitiva eso se entiende y por supuesto
que es información sensible por supuesto
que la información clasificada
pero
dudo si usted me pregunta sobre las
posibilidades las posibles repercusiones
tuvo que se llegue a dicho rápidamente
que se llega a montarla que se montó con
Wikileaks que además además y para más
sin riesgo ayudó a la amplificación del
escándalo estuvieron varios medios
principales
a lo largo de ancho de todo el mundo
aliados para para publicarlo y para irlo
publicando esto al final ha sido lo que
ha sido que podría ser casi
sin entrar en el fondo pero sí que ha
sido mucho más puntual que el escándalo
de hace 10 años el juego no más o menos
de Wikileaks Este es un tema que seguro
nos va a dar mucho más que hablar en el
futuro Francisco gracias a usted Por
ponerlo en perspectiva es Francisco
girado director de defensa seguridad y
aeroespacial de la consultora atreve a
la deseo que tenga un feliz día
Igualmente Ángela gracias a nuestros
televidentes se les pido que se queden
con nosotros unos segundos de pausa y ya
volvemos con más de directo a América
[Música]